una gestión austera y un gabinete
técnico bajo esa consigna luis arce
nombró a los 16 ministros de su gobierno
y se comprometió a restablecer el
ministerio de culturas disuelto bajo la
gestión interina de jeanine áñez el
mandatario de bolivia respondió la
renovación y evitó designar a
funcionarios cercanos al ex presidente
evo morales se rodeó de tecnócratas y
líderes sociales pero no dio lugar a
indígenas una medida que despertó
malestar entre las bases del movimiento
al socialismo y por la que pasa
nos informamos de la patética situación
en la que vive nuestro estado
plurinacional por eso hemos recurrido
a lo mejor que podíamos traer
para trabajar en un equipo en una
familia
porque lo que nos resta a los bolivianos
a las bolivianas
es simplemente trabajar para salir de la
crisis mientras tanto evo morales
regresó a territorio boliviano un año
después de su salida del poder
acompañado por el presidente argentino
alberto fernández el líder indígena
cruzó la frontera y se dio un baño de
masas en villazón
le dijieron el mango pueblo volver al
gobierno me llevó a bolivia ayer el más
ha vuelto al gobierno ahora está en
bolivia fracasaron hermanas y hermanos
morales será escoltado por una caravana
hasta la región del chapare donde espera
llegar el miércoles
la justicia de bolivia retiro días atrás
una orden de arresto contra el
exmandatario aunque todavía debe
enfrentar varias causas abiertas bajo el
gobierno provisorio de años
[Aplausos]